in the first few parts of this series we
learned about the history of coal in
Eastern Kentucky and how it's the client
has impacted the day-to-day lives of
Kentuckians in this part we'll look at a
side of Appalachia that you don't
normally hear about stop defining the
Appalachian region by poverty there are
a lot of good things that are happening
Appalachia our people here our mountains
our music our culture our food I've
always had a very particular way of
looking at Appalachia the way that's
been defined by poverty but on a recent
trip
I learned that Appalachia is so much
more despite the reason going to Donald
Trump in a 2016 election the people I
met didn't have much faith in what any
politician including the president could
do for them instead they're depending on
themselves and their communities I think
you know we're one of the last places
that it's socially accessible made fun
of and still be considered progressive
people still think that we wear no shoes
and have no teeth and live with dirt for
homes I mean we're just regular people
too and you know it's just hard too hard
to leave these mounds I guess that's why
the colosseo babies you know once a
hillbilly always real baby in these
mountains people are still trying to
come to grips with the reality of life
after coal I'll say it right brothers
down letting the nerves of people rise
up and figure out holes not coming back
the federal Feaster Kentucky's gonna be
what we really need is a different
diversified economy and we're not going
to have a diversified economy if we
always have it in our minds that we have
to be subservient to the coal industry
driving around Eastern Kentucky it's
obvious that the region is struggling
with the declining coal industry Homes
lie abandoned by people who have fled
the region and the most prevalent
businesses seem to be fast-food
restaurants but if you stumble over the
mountain to a town called Whitesburg in
Letcher County you might find like I did
a busy place with a couple of
restaurants and media and Art Center
even two competing tattoo parlors in
other words some hopes for the future of
an economy without coal for the owners
of heritage kitchen a new restaurant in
town
moving to Whitesburg with a homecoming
I've always wanted to be back home these
mountains have a Hall on people that are
from here even people who visit like
Daryl you know kind of got attached I
was a cost accounting for a fortune 500
company in Lexington I wanted to do
something that I really truly enjoyed
and I love to cook so when we had the
opportunity to move it's just was a
natural fit unlike so many who have left
the region looking for work Brad and
Daryl wanted to move back to help
revitalize their community hopefully
we're part of the economic solution here
we're trying to work with local farmers
to create a network of locally grown
food and that's been very very
successful and promising for us
Whitesburg has responded well to
heritage kitchen after just over a year
of opening Brad and Daryl already wants
to add a coffee shop and grow their
catering business his family actually
discouraged us from coming here they
said they're the business climate here
is so bad you'll never make it it will
be so hard on you but there's the sense
that you can create your own destiny
here
we have a daughter our names of Brooklyn
she's eight years old she's great she
doesn't feel the necessity or the need
to go away from here to do what she
wants to do she wants new
paleontologists I don't know how much
she can do tears but I think everybody
here at some point goes through the
ideas like I really I hate this place I
want to leave but then you know you just
go a little bit farther than your own
backyard
and you find people that are a whole lot
more like you than you ever thought of
and you're like well maybe I don't have
to leave where I want to be to feel like
I belong or do what I really want to do
aside from small businesses there are
some bigger possibilities for Appalachia
which could really help turn things
around one of those things is the
reclaim act the reclaim act is a bill
that's in Congress that would use 1
billion dollars to put people in coal
communities to work reclaiming abandoned
coal mines and creating economic
opportunities on those mines once
they're reclaimed for years coal
companies were required to pay into a
fund to clean up mines once the work
there was done that money could now be
used to create jobs and start new
projects like solar or wind farms
according to a recent survey 89% of
Appalachian both Democrats and
Republicans support the reclaim act but
first it has to clear Congress and get a
signature from the president when you
have a plan in these communities then
there is hope there for what can come
next people can see where they're going
in addition to the reclaim act many
former coal miners like Carl are talking
about the need for a cleaner and more
environmentally friendly energy industry
which means moving away from surface
mining a highly destructive process
which has been ongoing since the 70s
that flattens mountaintops destroy
forests and pollutes waterways
I think renewable energy could work here
in these mountains I really do this type
of land you could work leveling stuff
down you could use it for - putting
solar panels on it you could really do
some stuff like that here and create a
lot of jobs and it's job creation with
Eastern Kentucky and the rest of
Appalachia is need but as I learned in
order for its economy to successfully
transition out of coal Appalachia is
going to need every new opportunity it
can get
[Music]
I do hope that we can find a way to put
things back together ourselves instead
of relying on an industry coming back in
because an industry coming in and
leaving is what put us where we are
right now if anybody is watching this
that has a lot of investment capital
this is the place to come to it just
takes the sense of entrepreneurship
which is already here people here just
need capital and funding and the ideas
are here that they could be successful
with we're here and we're ready to you
know fight and make our home better for
all of us I just foresee a very vibrant
Eastern Kentucky coming back alive and I
hope I leave the street leaving Eastern
Kentucky with bittersweet
the reason is clearly struggling without
coal but I also found that it's rich
with culture good ideas and the
resilience that I never could have
imagined so while we're in Eastern
Kentucky we learned a lot about what the
transition from coal look like check out
part 1 and part 2 of our series where
you can learn exactly why coal was such
a big deal in the first place and how
its decline is hurting the everyday
people living there